- All hour, we've celebrated rad dads.
And while I saved a very
special dad for the end
this is what I'm liking.
(bouncy music)
So fathers are known
for giving life advice
whether it's cars, money, relationships
or maybe even how to caulk a sink.
Um, and thanks to TikTok.
A dad from Washington
State is giving that kind
of advice to millions.
Just take a look.
- I'm gonna show you how
to check your oil today.
It's really easy to do.
Just make sure your
automobile is relatively level
and that it's been sitting for a while.
Then the big fish is gonna swim on
the backside of the
rock. Come over the top.
I know it's hard to see
and the big fish is gonna drop
down through the waterfall.
Then you cinch it up.
- Oh my God. I love the big fish.
Bo started the Tiktok channel
called Dad Advice from Bo
with daughter, Emily. I love it.
And we have him on the line now.
What's up Bo? What's up Emily?
- Hey, nice to see you.
- [Kelly] OK. So I, Bo, I'm assuming
that this was more Emily's idea at first.
- Oh, absolutely.
In real life I'm actually
a very private person.
So when Emily proposed this idea to me
I immediately rejected it.
I didn't wanna have anything to do with it
but she's very persistent.
She kept coming back to me day
after day and she always
had a new reason to do it.
A new idea for me.
And then she came up
with this one this one
day where she said, listen
you have a dad that
you're always able to go
to for advice whenever you
want, which I still do.
And all the kids have you.
But what
if there's somebody out there
that doesn't have a dad?
- [Kelly] Amen.
- What if there's somebody out there
that could use that kind of advice?
Don't you wanna make some videos for them?
Yeah, I, I had to agree.
That's not a bad idea. So,
- [Kelly] Yeah
- We started making a couple of videos
and the responses that we've
gotten have been just amazing.
- Yeah. And she's, she's totally right.
Emily's totally right.
Some of us didn't grow
up with a dad around.
Luckily I did have some good guy friends
that did tell me how to, you know
change the tire and do
my oil, change my oil.
But, but there's Emily.
There's another reason that
you started this channel.
Can you share that with us?
- Yeah. I wish that it
was just a genius idea
but it was really born out of desperation.
I suffered a traumatic brain injury
in a soccer game and it
happened to the back of my head.
So you can't see it on my
face, but my body is very sick.
And so in 2020, try not to cry.
I just said to my parents, like
I don't wanna keep fighting anymore.
I don't have anything left in me.
And so starting the TikTok
was just my attempt to
do something every day.
And I thought I could put
something good out in the world
but what we got was an army
of people just fighting for me
and telling me to keep going.
And I don't, there's a
lot of people with my type
of brain injury in the world
and a lot of good dads.
So I don't know why we got
chosen to have this blessing
but we will do everything
we can to pay it forward.
- Absolutely. How are you
doing right now? Emily?
Are you doing better?
- I'm okay.
I'm fighting really hard.
And because of TikTok and
the money we've earned
I get to go to a brain
injury clinic next week
and try to get really, really well.
- Okay, alright. Hey, well
please, please let us know
if we can help in any way.
I didn't know that part of this story.
So please let us know if we can help.
And I have to say, is
this where y'all live?
This beautiful log cabin?
- Yeah, we are very lucky.
- In the, in the middle of the woods.
- Oh my God.
- We just wanted to say
your whole show is just
about good people and how much
good there is in the world.
And I think in the last couple of years
a lot of people started to question that
but we just wanna reiterate.
There is so much good in this world.
- Absolutely. Emily. You are. Emily. Woo.
You're breaking me right now.
Oh my God. I wish you were
here. I wanna hug you.
I don't know where you are, but I'd come.
I love a log cabin
and I love being out in
the middle of nowhere
says the girl who owns a ranch in Montana.
So I'm, I'm down with wherever you are.
Thank y'all so much and good luck
with whatever treatment
you're gonna, you're gonna do.
And, and let us know, please,
if we can help you in any way.
Bo thank you so much for
helping everybody out there
that maybe didn't have a daddy
to teach him stuff like that.
I'm liking y'all's post right now
(chime)
and I'm still wiping away
tears, but that's not all.
Our season long partner,
pilot pen makers of G2.
The go to pen of the Kelly Clarkson Show.
Want to honor ultimate overachievers.
Just like y'all.
So they're gonna be writing you a check
for a thousand dollars.
How's that sound?
All right?
- [Emily] Oh my gosh.
- All right!
I love you guys.
God bless, good luck.
And thank you so much for joining us.